PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome to
"Google Cloud Drawing Board,"
where we doodle our
way through the cloud.
Today's topic-- what
is Cloud Operations?
This video is divided
into chapters.
Watch the full
video, or skip ahead
to any new section
of your choice.
You know the time when you
want to see how your cloud
deployment is behaving
or if something's
broken in production and
your users might be impacted?
You are scrambling
because there are too
many tools to look through to
find and resolve the issue.
That's where Cloud
Operations comes in.
It's a suite of products
to monitor, troubleshoot,
and operate your
services at scale,
enabling your DevOps,
SREs, or IT operations
teams to utilize the
Google's SRE best practices.
It offers integrated
capabilities
for monitoring, logging,
and advanced observability
services, like Trace,
Debugger, and Profiler.
The end-to-end operations suite
includes capturing signals,
monitoring systems,
managing incidents,
troubleshooting issues
with built-in telemetry,
out-of-the-box dashboards,
recommendations, and more.
So let's see how does
Cloud Operations work.
First, Cloud Logging, which
is a fully managed and highly
scalable service that
aggregates log data
from all your infrastructure
and applications
into a single location.
It collects the log data
from Google Cloud Services
automatically.
And you can feed custom logs
through Cloud Logging agent,
open-source Fluentd, or the API.
It gives you complete
control to decide
how and where to store these
logs, including keeping them
in Cloud Logging, exporting
to Cloud Storage for archival,
BigQuery for analytics,
or streaming them
via Cloud Pub/Sub to a
third-party destination.
Log Viewer gives you
powerful capabilities
to filter the logs, convert
them to log-based metrics
for monitoring, alerting,
analyzing, and visualizing.
Cloud Monitoring
provides observability
across your apps
and infrastructure
regardless of where it is--
Google Cloud, on prem
or in other clouds.
It supports a variety
of metrics integrations
and allows you to define custom
metrics unique to your use case
and even send those metrics
to external systems.
Using the Metrics Explorer
and Monitoring Query Language,
you can analyze these
metrics on the fly,
identifying
correlations, and easily
add the corresponding
charts to a dashboard.
You can use out-of-the-box or
custom-built dashboards to get
a consolidated view of the
health of your infrastructure
service or application
and easily spot anomalies.
But we know that you cannot
sit around all day looking
at dashboards, so Cloud
Monitoring provides alerting,
where you can create policies
to alert on performance metrics,
uptime checks, and
service-level indicators.
Now let's focus our attention on
advanced observability feature
Trace.
Trace provides
visualization and analysis
to understand request
flow, service topology,
and latency issues in your app.
Debugger allows you
to inspect the state
of running applications after
deployment without needing
to stop or slow it down.
Profiler continuously analyzes
your code's performance
on each service so that
you can improve its speed
and reduce your cost.
And it is designed to run in
production with effectively
no performance impact.
While Trace is used to track
relationships and latency
between services,
Profiler tracks
this across the individual
functions in your code base.
And Debugger helps find
the root cause from method
to the specific
problematic piece of code.
Now, you can use the
Cloud Console or the API
to use Cloud Operations tools.
All these tools offer a
very generous free tier
to make it easy for
you to get started.
From the security
perspective, all your data
is encrypted at
rest and in transit.
Your security-focused audit
logs are automatically
available in Cloud Logging,
telling you who did what,
where, and when.
And with Access
Transparency, you
can always stay in compliance
because it captures
the actions Google personnel
takes while offering you
support.
I bet that keeping your
applications up and running
and making sure your
customers are happy
is your number-one priority.
And Cloud Operations
helps you do just that.
By using service-level
objectives that
work across all application
types and cloud environments
or using error reporting
to identify bugs
in your applications,
Cloud Operations
provides your ops teams with
the out of the box observability
to monitor your infrastructure
and your applications.
Want to get started?
Check out the free trial.
[MUSIC PLAYING]